hello welcome to breakthroughs from
science mission I am sadashiva pi and
going to discuss couple of breakthrough
papers published in the week of August
11 let's start first we will discuss a
paper published by Johanna and
colleagues in self reports that
indicates an insignificant role for stem
cells in the regeneration of hepatocytes
during liver injury why is this paper so
important liver stem cells are thought
to replenished last he parasites during
chronic liver injury there are
conflicting reports available on the
contribution of lsi's to liver
regeneration authors failed to detect
hepatocytes that were not derived from
pre-existing hepatocytes in chronic
liver injury this paper concludes that
stem cells may not play any role during
chronic liver injury let's look at the
data one week after genetically labeling
hepatocytes author started feeding mice
the choline deficient a tienen
supplemented CDE diet to india's chronic
liver injury for up to three weeks hui
no staining for eyfp and hn f 4 Alpha
indicated very small number of eyfp
negative parasites and quantitation
revealed nonfed traced hepatocytes at a
frequency of less than 1% others looked
into if liver stem cells are capable of
giving rise to hepatocytes that reside
in biliary structures they used a
different fate racing model as shown
here enjoyed leavers showed a negligible
frequency fate raised her pet aside
identified by immunostaining for major
urinary protein mob specific for
hepatocytes recovery after injury also
did not increase in the frequency fate
raised hepatocytes next to assess
contribution of mission camel cells to
hepatocytes regeneration a new mouse
model was generated using
platelet-derived growth factor
receptor beta immunostaining for the
mission femoral cell markers desmond or
the hepatocyte markers map showed
negligible faith-based hepatocyte
numbers in both injured and non-injured
livers authors repeated hepatocyte fate
racing with a mouse model that can be
analyzed by direct fluorescence and
immunostaining for a pet ascites in MA
authors found non fare traced
hepatocytes detected before and after CD
eat diet feeding are not newly generated
by non hepatocyte source but are
pre-existing hepatocytes that were not
labeled quantitation also showed same
results this is as clearly demonstrate
that new hepatocytes are not formed from
stem cells after liver injury next let's
look into a paper published by Jessica
and colleagues in Nature Materials
authors demonstrate that matrix
stiffness but no other parameters are
important for stem cell differentiation
why is this paper so important Provost
Sam cell in vitro proliferation and
differentiation is crucial for stem cell
therapy dicks ECM parameters regulating
stem cell growth and differentiated
differentiation are not clearly
understood authors demonstrate ECM
porosity and tethering may not be
important for stem cell differentiation
they also show that matrix stiffness
might play a crucial role in stem cell
differentiation others developed for 13
and 30 kilopascal kpa extracellular
matrix with different porosities using
acrylamide and miss acrylamide that
correspond stiffness of adipose tissue
muscle and osteoid respectively authors
tested a Depot genetic differentiation
as assessed by oil red o presence and
found differentiation in over forty
percent of the cells on all four KP a
substrate
regardless of hydrogel formulation and
was directly dependent on substrate
stiffness as 30 kPa substrates were
negative indicating the differentiation
dependent on the stiffness rather than
porosity next to understand the role of
protein tethering authors directly
incorporated various amounts of our GD a
short sell adhesive peptide from
fibronectin into polyacrylamide backbone
to make the same gel Fitness stiffness
of 4 13 and 30 kilo Pascal's a hydroxy
coumarine die conjugated activated peg
rgd confirmed that the peptide was
incorporated in a dose-dependent manner
the same images of dried hydrogens
showed similar pore sizes regardless of
the concentration of acylated peg a GD
incorporated within each substrate cells
underwent osteogenic differentiation on
30 kph hydrogels independently of our GD
concentration indicating tethering may
not have much role to play in the
differentiation to understand the role
of stiffness on differentiation authors
used polyacrylamide pack our GD
hydrogen's in the absence of protein
tethers as shown here pdms substrates
that are stiffer than 30 kPa also did
not order osteogenic differentiation
others did several other experiments to
confirm the role of stiffness in
cellular differentiation thank you for
watching science breakthroughs from
science